JOHN DOLHUN: You got the sock?
OK.
So I'm just going to put
the sock in here.
He's going to catch it.
[LOUD POPPING NOISE]
There it goes.
Let's check his sock out.
Is it still OK?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
NARRATOR: It's day one.
MIT instructor John Dolhun
introduces the course.
JOHN DOLHUN: You're going to
learn basic skills that will
form building blocks in your
future adventures at MIT and
outside of MIT.
NARRATOR: That is,
if you pass.
And what exactly
does that take?
JOHN DOLHUN: You're going to get
about 14 hours of lecture,
about 52 to 75 hours of lab.
We only have two and
a half weeks.
You have to be able to think out
of the box, be creative,
and most importantly, be mindful
of your mistakes.
PHIL: The hoods are
over there...
NARRATOR: Next, safety
training.
Remember, for many of the
students this is their first
time in the lab.
No flip-flops, no shorts, no
skirts, but most importantly,
gloves and goggles starting
tomorrow.
PHIL: They tell you to wear
goggles and everything.
And you don't really realize the
importance until you have
a piece of glass flying
at your face.
NARRATOR: After four hours of
lecture, the students finally
check into the lab.
TENGFEI: My name is Tengfei.
And this is Phil.
And we will be the TAs
for this class.
This is all the equipment you
should have in your drawer and
the cabinet.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
AUDIENCE: Oh.
Nevermind.
ETHAN: I guess I get the antique
shelf or something.
But we'll work around it.
NARRATOR: After checking in, the
students get introduced to
a technique called
nuclear magnetic
resonance, or NMR for short.
NMR helps chemists piece
together a molecule structure.
The students put their mystery
molecule into a thin tube and
lower it into a very powerful
magnetic field.
This forces certain atoms in the
sample to align themselves
either with or against
the field.
Aligning with the field
takes less energy.
So there are a few more
atoms aligned with
than against the field.
A pulse of energy makes the
extra atoms aligned with the
field flip.
The computer measures how much
energy this takes and produces
a spectrum.
The amount of energy it takes
to flip an atom depends on
what other atoms
are next to it.
That means you can tell which of
the atoms are connected and
put together a picture of what
the whole molecule looks like.
That's the theory.
But the students are about to
learn that dealing with a real
live machine is not so simple.
ANNE RACHUPKA: Awful lot
we're going to go over.
These are live magnets.
They are in field
at all times.
You cannot go anywhere near it
with iPod, iPhone, any USB
storage devices, no push pins,
no staples, no bobby pins.
We have our little sample?
I have taken people to the
hospital because they've put
an NMR tube through
their hand.
Definitely don't bring your
wallet anywhere near the
instrument.
This costs probably more than
one year tuition to MIT.
Obviously, this is not
going to work.
Do not, under any circumstances,
insert your
sample without the air on.
You guys have any burning
questions?
You're all going to be experts
the first time you sit down
[INAUDIBLE].
Right?
LEALIA: We were all like, uh--
ANTHONY: Mmm.
ETHAN: Oh dear God.
JULIE: Can we just not talk
about this anymore?
NARRATOR: The day
is finally over.
And it's time to head home.
IKE: It was pretty intimidating
because I walked
into this class with all
these smart people.
ETHAN: I felt, I guess, a
little bit overwhelmed.
I wasn't exactly sure what
to expect from 5.301.
EMILY: I didn't expect it
to be this much work.
I'm kind of doubting whether I
made the right choice to take
this class.
ETHAN: Oh my God, what
have I gotten into ?
ANTHONY: I am going to
fail this class.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: I've always been
a fan of cupcakes.
But now that they're popular,
I'm a big fan of cupcakes.
ANTHONY: Oh, can you
make us dessert?
SPEAKER: No.
ANTHONY: Why not?
SPEAKER: What is this, like
an ice cream social?
[MUSIC PLAYING]